قطعه من الفردوس هكذا وصفت الاعلانات مجمع
رونيسانس ريزيدانس السكني عند افتتاحه قبل
10 سنوات
وبهدف جذب النخبه لهذا المجمع السكني
والمؤلف من 249 شقه تم الترويج له على انه
مقاوم للزلازل ولكن عندما حانت لحظه
الحقيقه لاختبار كفاءته بعيدا عن هذه
الشعارات التسويقيه انهار المبنى السكني
باكمله هذه الشقق والبيوت الفاخره تحولت
الى غبار رغم صمود الكثير من المباني
القديمه من حوله موجه السياء واسعه وخيبه
امل ساده الناجين الذين بقوا واقفين بجانب
اكوام من الانقاض في انتظار اخبار ذويهم
عاش شقيق هنا 10 سنوات قيل انها امنه من
الزلزال لكن يمكنك رؤيه النتيجه
تم تقديمه على انه اجمل سكن في العالم انه
في حاله مروعه لا يوجد فيه اسمنت ولا حديد
مناسب انه جحيم حقيقي الغضب الشعبي في
مدينه هاتاي التي يقع فيها هذا المجمع
تتزايد بشان ما يعتبره الاتراك ممارسات
بناء فاسده عشرات الاشخاص اتهموا
المقاولين باستخدام مواد رخيصه وغير
مناسبه واتهموا ايضا السلطات التركيه
بالتهاون في الموافقه على تراخيص الانشاء
دون المستوى المطلوب
وثائق متناثره بين الانقاض تثبت كميه
التلاعب المتعلقه بسلامه المباني ومراقبه
الجوده
وتثبت ايضا فساد المطور العقاري الذي
اعتقل في مطار اسطنبول بينما كان يستعد
للهروب نحو الجبل الاسود الممارسات
الفاسده هو مخالفات قوانين البناء لم تكن
حاضره فقط في هذا المبنى الفاخر
فهناك نحو 50% من اجمالي 20 مليون مبنى في
تركيا تخالف قوانين البناء الامر الذي جعل
السلطات التركيه تحقق مع 246 مشتبها بهم
حتى الان سلطان العظام العربيه